one of my favorite go-to breakfast -
options I love making overnight oats so
really quick simple you sort of soak
some oats overnight with some almond
milk bitter cacao mixing some berries
from some crushed cashews nuts so that's
a really good sort of a nice
carbohydrate-based breakfast or if I'm
gonna make a fatty breakfast it'll be
like a scrambled egg or Run omelet with
some smoked salmon some of that ice we
cook it easy and you know give you
energy for the day so what you gonna
make for me this morning then so this is
what we preach this is one of my recipes
from one of my first books it's called a
fats me up smoothie so it's basically
smoothie of some almond milk some Greek
yogurt and some avocado so healthy fats
really good for the heart and this is
gonna give you energy and then mixing
with some nice carbohydrates we've got
some berries blueberries and
blackberries and a little squeeze of
lime so yeah and a little bit of honey
just give a bit of flavor and that's it
that's me up smoothie okay well you saw
that and I just want to ask you about
healthy fats because I've noticed that
in all your books even in your latest
one 30-minute meals yeah you don't
include any of the nutritional value
that's in any of the ingredients and you
certainly don't include the calorie
count why is that so this is the one
thing that I get criticized for about
mostly personal trainers or other
coaches online saying you know why don't
you list the calories and the macros but
I don't think that calorie counting is a
healthy way to look at food I think you
need to focus on you know healthy home
cook in regular home workouts and
teaching yourself through healthy
cooking and just portion control I think
if you if I list the calories everyone's
gonna think that's the perfect portion
for them but you might need less energy
than I need and so I always say my
introductions adapt the portions based
on your energy demands the government
did say that they're going to consult on
the fact that they want restaurants and
their menus to have the amount of
calories that are in each dish they
thought it would be a good idea for
those who are trying to watch what they
eat to assess what they're taking in
everyday you don't think that's a good
idea I just think when you have like a
daily tout a target of say let's say
when any 2,000 calories a day it's very
rigid and it doesn't allow for
flexibility if you eat if you do eat out
with your friends or if you don't have a
glass of wine you know I think and then
there's this also the thing of the low
calorie diet industry where people will
say Armand only 1000 calories today but
they're not think about where that's
coming from they might save their
calories in a packet of biscuits at
night first up then we've got some
almond milk okay if you don't like
almond milk you could always use normal
milk I use full fat milk so I love it
milks my new things that any good I
yeah I was pretty tasty and as they
obviously saw and so right I've got some
Greek yogurt little dollop of that so we
throw some lean in 15 styles yeah go on
yeah Greek yogurt going in tonight
Severn don't get crazy with the pan even
if you like it sweet a little a little
squeeze like that yeah like you said
everything in moderation and then what's
up ready quick and easy
that's me up smoothie can we call it the
sunrise smoothie now you can call it the
sunrise movie but I don't I wouldn't
have this every day this isn't something
I don't you know recommend continuing on
shakes trying to have a different kind
of variation of different things so a
good balance you don't want to rely on
you know protein shakes or kind of
smoothies every day because this is a
good little snack but I'd still want to
have a good breakfast as well alongside
it right don't have a little go yeah let
bottoms up yeah good yeah okay that gets
my approval that can definitely be
called the sunrise smoothie families
young children who don't have access to
Instagram and fancy diet plans is it
something you'd like to I do they advise
the government on or NHS advisors in
terms of how to get children motivated
in fitness and interested in food why
Fitness is getting pushed out the
curriculum because it's not prioritized
so you know kids are less active and
combine that with an unhealthy diet
potentially at home and within school
then it's a massive issue and so I am
really pushing that and I'm using the
platform they're on which is YouTube and
trying to disrupt it and say right
you're gonna watch your channel and your
vloggers and stuff but try and do a
little workout of me yeah think
differently about the way you are doing
things and that's my main kind of I'm
not going at it from a food perspective
as much it's more from a fitness
perspective to get kids active and it's
amazing of all the things I do it's the
one thing that makes me the happiest
like seeing the little videos and all
the kids doing it and stuff every day
no equipment I just tuned in hundreds of
kids all over the world I'm just their
PE teachers for 20 minutes and you know
the stuff the feedback we're getting
from it is incredible people just love
it I want to show some of the little
kids doing it so they'll do it in their
classroom brilliant there's some
fantastic press ups there from that kid
and I mean literally in the minute
they're fast from there there are gonna
be comparisons with Jamie Oliver he
likes to cook quickly as well and he's
also got very involved in children's
nutrition and he's called for a ban on
TV ads for junk food targeted at
children at certain times is that the
kind of route we should be going down
that will have an impact so you know a
small impact on a certain amount of
people but I think it's education as
well like because you can remove TVs on
the buses it's on the way to school it's
you know marketing is everywhere I think
they have a responsibility of the
companies to not target products the
children if they know it's not healthy
for them but they're driven by profit so
know they're always doing pushing those
products but I think ultimately it's
about education whether that's at home a
school about nutrition and what these
children should be put in their bodies
because it's if you combine an unhealthy
diet with the sedentary lifestyle we're
getting sicker and sicker and more
overweight at the moment we're quite a
way into social free September where
we're trying to encourage people to
reduce their use of social media to see
what benefits there may be to that just
what you think about social media
because your business is on social media
2.3 million Instagram followers do you
think you'd be where you are without it
well first of all I'm a hundred percent
addicted to my phone but I am my mom is
my dad is everyone around me is really
addicted their phone whether you like to
admit it or not we're just so used to
scrolling and filling that time out with
with our phone and our smartphones but
you know Instagram completely changed my
life like it allowed me to connect with
means of people it allowed me to reach
people all over the world with my
mission which is to inspire you to cook
a healthy recipe or do a workout so I
think if I started today though with the
same kind of motivation in the same
videos I wouldn't have a success because
when I started it was like just you know
just starting up no we're doing it
where's now there's so many people doing
recipes and fitness and online plans
that I think I had a good idea at the
right time so I got lucky with the
timing thank you for having breakfast
with me well to be fair you made
I don't feel too guilty cuz it okay a
couple of minutes bottoms up